RUNNING.
SWIMMING.
RUNNING!
Run off.
I've got a video to do.
Sup guys, Trace here.
Thanks for watching DNews today.
In High School, I was on the track and cross
country teams, but I was ALSO on the swim
team.
Running is exercise.
Swimming is too.
They're both exercise, and they're both great
in their own way.
But, which is BETTER?
ITS TIME FOR A SCIENCE THROWDOWN.
Let's tackle the benefits: Running is easy,
most people have two legs and can probably
walk and run -- if imperfectly.
It’s great cardiovascular exercise.
Running USA, the major running and foot racing
advocacy organization, says 30 million people
took to the streets at least 50 times per
person in 2012.
People who run or jog regularly, even for
a 5 to 10 minutes a day are healthier than
non-runners, and have a 45% lower cardiovascular
mortality.
Running can build bone density and runners
have later-onset age-related disability and
3 years added to their lives in comparison
to non-runners.
Swimming has a little higher learning curve.
You might have to take swimming lessons, for
one.
But once you've gotten past that hurdle, the
benefits are clear.
Swimming is ALSO great cardiovascular exercise.
A 2008 peer-reviewed study in the International
Journal of Aquatic Research and Education
followed over 40,000 men for 13 years and
found lower mortality rates than people who
were sedentary, walkers, and runners.
Resistance training is better than pure cardio
for building bone density and muscle; and
swimming has resistance, if small.
In fact, the butterfly is considered the single
most taxing movement in sports -- it's more
difficult than bicycling 14 miles per hour
(23kph), or running a 10 minute mile.
Calories burned for either running or swimming
vary depending on your weight and the difficulty
level.
Though overall the journal of the American
Statistical Association found swimmers will
burn 25 percent more calories, but runners
can usually go for longer.
Running's biggest drawback is impact problems,
right?
It's an impact sport, my Dad always said!
Maybe not!
A 21-year-long Stanford study of 1,000 runners
and non-runners found joint problems were
found equally across both groups.
Minimalist or barefoot running and thick running
shoes also battle within running culture,
but in a comprehensive study of shoes versus
no shoes found the problem was people.
If we're used to running with shoes, and try
barefoot we hurt ourselves; and the opposite
is true too.
So fight about if you want, but if you do
it right, the science seems to say they're
both fine,.
Long-distance intensive running can cause
health problems -- we've talked about it on
DNews before..
Swimming has an obvious drawback; drowning.
It does happen, though it's pretty damn rare.
Chlorine in swimming pools isn't great for
your skin, but its there to kill disease-causing
contaminants.
But kids’ over-exposure to chlorine can
reduce testosterone and infant over-exposure
cause respiratory problems.
This is after hundreds of hours in a pool
environment; so maybe not something everyone
should be concerned about.
It can also be alleviated by swimming in a
lake, ocean, or a saltwater pool.
It seems pretty much a tie to me.
Overall, both swimming and running promote
cardiovascular health, as long as you don't
overdo it, and you get the proper training.
With both swimming and running make sure you
talk to someone about proper technique if
you want to do it right.
Just because you can doesn't mean you know
how to do it properly.
So which do YOU think is better?
Why don't you tell us?
I like both.
Exercise is hard, but so is Going Off Grid.
It's not for everyone.
Going off grid explores the lives of those
who choose a different path.
This pro-snowboarder lives in a tiny house
in Northern California.
The whole thing is only 225 square feet.